i wanted to be liked and i wanted people
to think i was interesting and so i had
to pretend and the voice in my head this
ego kept saying i'm a piece of [ __ ] that
i still
really have a problem with and i've got
to get better at when you're in that
headspace
not much makes sense anymore and you
have to start questioning everything
otherwise you just get stuck
the new path that i've forged which
isn't necessarily as mainstream and
isn't as shiny or celebrated or whatever
but i can be
truly me and there's room to move and
there's room to change it feels
liberating quick one can you do me a
favor if you're listening to this and
hit the subscribe button the follow
button wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much fern cotton to
me she's the definition of authenticity
and she absolutely exudes self-awareness
and wisdom because she spent the last 10
20 years
understanding herself
she went through this remarkable journey
of entering the public spotlight at just
15 years old where she started working
on tv and up until her 30s when she
worked on bbc's radio 1 she remained
front and center in british media
but behind the scenes something else was
going on feeling like she wasn't being
true to herself and she was living
someone else's life
like she was wearing a mask it all came
to a head in her early 30s where she
realized that something had to change
if her panic attacks and her depression
was to end she had to make big life
changes
and this meant leaving her job in
pursuing a completely
different uncertain
unknown path
her story is remarkable but this
conversation was so incredibly valuable
because fern is wise she's done the work
and as she sits here today she's able to
tell us to tell me to tell you the
listener how to avoid making some of the
mistakes that she made in her life so
that we can all get to our own
very happy place
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
i
one of the things that i've got from
reading about you reading about um
your story and reading your books was
how
self-analytical
and self-aware
you've become as the years have gone by
and it's pretty much central to a lot of
what you do is really understanding
yourself having these conversations on a
happy place and understanding others
which becomes a bit of a mirror
sometimes when you have a podcast so
when you look back at the
the start of your life
what were the things that were really
formative to you
that you've noticed in hindsight
i guess like most people it's
my parents
and
their work ethic and their outlook on
life
and
they're very very different people so
i've picked up very different things
from both of them so my mom is
tenacious very honest she gets things
done
she's been very dynamic over the years
but her work ethic has been amazing like
when i was growing up she had
anywhere between one and four jobs at
any one time having to just sort of
juggle life and get money on the table
so i had that sort of like tenacious
force
in my life but and then i also had my
dad who's so laid back really super
chilled
super creative he only retired a couple
of years ago although he's sort of
started working again but he was a sign
writer
throughout his whole working life
so i would go and watch him paint these
beautiful signs by hand obviously back
in the day
and he was always drawing and painting
at home and i would do the same so i've
always had a huge love of of art and
creating
and my dad's a really good story to
hello and he's very funny and my mum's
really social and really brilliant at
talking to people so i i kind of just
observed them you know i wasn't actively
doing it as a kid but by osmosis you you
take in
all of this information and
and just what you're seeing as a as a
child growing up so
i
have my mum and dad to thank for
everything really you know they they
gave me the sort of stability and love
to do what i wanted but also they showed
me work ethic
which i've always really held on tight
to because
i want to do well and i'm not
scared to say that i i want to to
succeed and do well in what i'm doing
and i know that requires a lot of work
what about school how are you in school
i heard not so not so great
um
i was good i guess when i was tiny i
wanted to stay in line i wasn't a rebel
i didn't want to get in trouble i was
terrified of authority or getting a
detention so i was pretty well behaved
and then i guess in my teen years i
started to just think
this is so boring and it's gray it's
gray outside and it's gray in here and
there must be
something other than this sort of
suburban life that i'm in i mean it was
all fine i was very lucky kid who grew
up with loving parents and a brother and
i had a school to go to but i just found
it so boring and that's where i just
started daydreaming constantly and i
guess that's where i started getting in
a teeny bit of trouble i was dreaming of
all of these other options other than
the ones i was being presented you know
you have to fill in the form of
what career option are you going to have
and it would always come back with
something that was relatively social but
it was nothing to do with what i was
interested in so i thought i'm not doing
any of this crap i want to do something
that makes my heart sing and that that
was always at that stage performing
in some way so i i luckily found a
brilliant local dance and drama school
it was in a church hall it was run by
all of these
young cool brilliant dancers singers
actors who were all in the west end
doing stuff but then running this little
local dance school on the side and that
was my everything so at school i was
just like watching the clock thinking
when can i get out of here to get to my
dance school
and i danced every day after school all
saturday all sunday
and that just felt
incredible like it was pure escapism
getting to just listen to amazing music
and learn
incredible dance routines i'm so
grateful to alex and chris that the two
people that that ran the dance school
and um
it just was the the coolest place to be
and to hang out and i would spend every
second there that i could so if i'd
asked you at that age what you want to
be when you grow up
post that dance school experience what
would you have said to me probably an
actor or
a like a backing dancer on top of the
pops was very appealing at that point
like i want to be in a crop top and
cargo pants
dancing behind a cool pop star that was
very appealing to me but i think i
really wanted to act because it felt
like pure escapism and we did all these
brilliant shows little tiny local
theaters but
really overly rehearsed and sort of you
know well done well thought through by
our
sort of dance school teachers and we had
amazing teachers you know people
straight from cats coming off stage and
teaching us routines or saturday night
fever whatever it might be
and it yeah it just felt exciting and
fun and something completely different
to the
mundane reality of going to school and
you know my parents working really hard
and just that mundane routine it just
felt like a complete break from it so i
think acting
was was the goal but i went very
off-piste did you believe when you were
13-14 that that was
possible
you believed it was possible yeah i
don't know why because i didn't know
anyone in that world
it i was a local dancer wasn't it sort
of like radar or even sylvia young's a
local dance school in a church
but i think the combination of being a
big dreamer like having wild fantasies
that i would just love escaping to
obviously before phones and social media
so your imagination was kind of where it
was at
and i would dream big and also my
parents they were never sort of like
pushy stage parents they were too busy
working but they were certainly
encouraging like you like this stuff you
keep doing it you know go all day
saturday go all day sunday it was
certainly encouraging
and obviously that combined with a huge
amount of naivety allowed me to believe
that i could do it and i think it's good
to have that naivety as a youngster
because you become jaded as you get
older and you see the pitfalls and you
see where you've made mistakes and i
miss that naivety because i don't really
have any of it anymore i kind of know
what i'm stepping into
i second guess the bad stuff that's
going to happen i'm probably overly
cautious whereas back then i could be
ridiculously
wild and brave because i was naive and
it got me somewhere and i sometimes miss
that naivety i guess
i couldn't relate more to that feeling
of just the preciousness of naivety um
and also how that decays as we become
adults and the world starts to
make us be a bit more realistic
really boring realistic imprisoning it
is 15 years old you get a spot on a
disney show by
hockey by crooks it seems that it was
quite a yeah
fate i guess really it was
like most brilliant game-changing
moments lots of factors so i was at this
local dance school
and one of the moms of another kid
worked in tv
she had said to one of the um dance
school teachers
we want to audition a couple of kids or
i know someone that's auditioning kids
for this
this disney club show
so i went along to this audition with my
nan because my mum was at work
and my nan obviously this was completely
not my nan's world whatsoever my dear
nan sylvia so we went into london to
kensington to this
audition space and there were loads of
kids i felt completely out of place they
were all from the big dance schools anna
chers sylvia young's and they were all
talking about that and saying oh
what show are you doing they're all in
les mis or whatever and i was going oh
[ __ ] i haven't done anything i go to a
local dance when i do little shows in my
local theater i had done nothing
of any prestige and i felt like i
shouldn't be there and i was trying to
not let that get the better of me but
again i think naivety and lack of
experience really
helped me like benefited me in that
circumstance and i went into the little
audition room and i was told to speak to
the camera which i'd never done before
because i'd just done stuff on stage
where you're dancing or
acting out a scene
so i thought why not am i talking to a
camera i don't even know
what that is or how i meant to do that
so i was just me which was what they
were luckily looking for i was just a
kid
chatting about stuff that i liked which
was like
hanson and watching top of the pops and
zoey ball and i talked about it with
enthusiasm because i was enthusiastic
about those things as a kid
and i somehow
blagged my way on to this
tv show on itv you know a big there was
only five tv channels back then or maybe
even four so it was a great exposure
piece and
but at the same time due to a lack of
social media
i was allowed to grow naturally and to
make mistakes and to be bloody awful
without much critique because there
wasn't really any
so i had you know amazing tv producers
teaching me the ropes and letting me
experiment and work out who i was on
camera and um and i've discovered i
really liked it
imposter syndrome you talked there you
said um you said a sentence there you
said i felt like i shouldn't be here
how was that the first sort of real dose
of imposter syndrome that you had
encountered in your life without a doubt
because i
i moved out of my safe little world of
being in
east coast where i slip all these little
suburban towns that i was living in or
doing the theatre
school in
where i had all my friends there and it
was safe and they all
had the same background as me and
nobody had been in that world so i felt
really safe and then moving into this
other world with stage school kids or
then eventually being on a tv set with
professional people from the worlds of
tv who'd been doing it for years i felt
wildly out of place
but
i don't think that's ever left me
i think i've always
kept that feeling like i don't really
belong in it
one of the things i'd noticed from
reading about that part of your life is
that you'd kind of it seemed like you'd
started to kind of overcompensate for
that feeling of um imposter syndrome by
working exceptionally hard and it's
funny because you know when you were
describing your mother's work ethic
there it sounded somewhat similar just
that we've got to keep this steam engine
running we've got to keep shoveling the
coal into the engine or it's going to or
it might stop right i think that's i
guess an element of coming from
suburbia into the the limelight and
somewhat not feeling like you're going
to be there is that that fear that it
might also be taken away at some point
right without a doubt i mean i don't
think you lose the feeling of your your
upbringing you might lose bits of it and
work your own you know your own thought
processes into life but i think it's
always there and i'll probably always
have a kind of working class
ethic because that's what i was brought
up with
so i have always over compensated
and i think i still do but i'm a little
braver in not conforming to what is
expected of me and having to do
mainstream tv or having to do
any mainstream broadcasting i'm trying
to do
more of my own stuff where i feel i can
experiment more be
truly authentic
and not have impostor syndrome because i
don't in my own space luckily when i'm
doing my podcast or i'm writing or we do
a festival whatever it might be
i do feel
comfortable and safe but not in a way
that dead ends me there's always room to
improve
new things to learn
more people to listen to which is a key
part of what i do now but i don't have
that horrible
feeling of i shouldn't be here on this
fancy tv set with all of these people
that belong here i i don't think i've
ever lost that weirdly and it maybe
feels like a bit of a teenage hangover
but
i i've never felt comfortable in that
space or like i truly belonged there
really what was the adverse consequence
of not feeling like you belonged there
throughout that period of your life not
being myself right because i think
i mean
not you know i wasn't sort of running
from myself entirely but i was certainly
i felt for a long period of time
too boring or too
average to be
in that position i thought you had to be
complicated or exceptionally something
to be in that space whereas i don't
believe that anymore i think everyone's
got their own worth and their own
beautiful spirit that is worth paying
forward but at that time i thought how
can i be here this kid from the suburbs
who what do i know why am i
in front of the camera
so
i certainly
i guess over accentuated who i was or
was a bit too smiley a bit too
enthusiastic a bit too everything
to
i get i guess get people to like me i
wanted to be liked that's the name of
the game a lot of the time in that
industry if people like you you have a
job if you're not liked
you don't have a job so
i wanted to be liked and i wanted people
to think i was interesting and that i
had some worth and had something to say
i didn't believe i did so i had to
pretend that i had some worth there and
and make it look like i did whereas now
with the work i do i believe through my
own life experiences the people that
i've learned from
the work that i've put in to be able to
write the way i do and interview people
the way that i do i can see my own worth
i can feel my own worth but for years i
didn't know what it was
you've had
i don't know how long it was but you
know at least probably a decade there of
living
almost you know professionally every day
um living out almost like a character or
being someone for the public for the
radio for the tv
um a lot of people have that in their
own lives in in various ways they might
be doing something professionally which
isn't like truly in aligned with who
they really are
tell me about the consequence of that
then of 10 years or or more of playing a
role and your life being
um not authentic to who you actually are
what's the consequence of that
i think you start creating your own
barriers it's only you that that's doing
that because we've all got the freedom
to be more authentic or to try new
things or to just
rock up to a situation fully as you we
can all do that it's scary but we can do
it and as you say i know i didn't do it
for years and years probably way more
than a decade certainly you know the
first 10 years of my career i didn't
know what that meant i just turned up
and was as happy as i could be and
enthusiastic and read the lines try not
to slip up over my words and went home
and felt chuffed and then the next
decade in my 20s that's where i felt
like oh i'm a bit boring i need to kind
of be a bit more exciting or whatever it
is that people want me to be
and
you stop yourself from moving into new
areas because you just think this is
what the public want or the boss wants
so i will be
enthusiastic and or if i was on the
radio i will be happy and improve
people's day by
bringing music and happiness whatever
whereas now
i'm just me so if i'm not feeling great
i will turn up to
a podcast a radio show or if i'm writing
as i am
i did a recording just before christmas
the day after one of my cats had died
and i'd had my cat for 20 years
and you know you've got a pet you know
it they're part of your family and i was
deeply grieving and i thought i'm not
going to cancel because i think there's
value in me turning up like this but i'm
not going to pretend that i feel any
different so i'm going to
answer with these emotions bubbling up
and i'm going to be
me and i have much less
care for people's response to that or
their reaction to it i just think
there's worth in all of it
if people don't listen to that they
don't have to that's that's their choice
but i'm not going to pretend anymore
that i'm anything other than how i am on
that day
but i've had to
forge a new path to do that i don't
think i could be
doing this
in the old spaces that i worked in
there's not as much room for it
i'm not talking about that in a
derogatory way because i had a great
period of learning from doing all that
stuff
but the new path that i've forged which
isn't necessarily as mainstream and
isn't necessarily as
shiny or celebrated or whatever
but i can be truly me
and there's room to move and there's
room to change and
it feels liberating i guess i feel very
lucky you know that's a lucky space to
have created
so you were
in essence living a very one-dimensional
life through that period and i've you
know i speak to i speak to jake about
this sometimes about how when you're on
tv you're there to do a very sort of
one-dimensional job i've learned from
doing this podcast that it's this
podcast is like therapy for me because i
get to be multi-dimensional i get to be
my true self and honest and also the
medium of podcasting as well allows for
depth and context that five-minute
little news clips on good morning
britain don't allow and you describe
that as liberation um i
i find that like incredibly um
incredibly important and it's i was just
thinking as you're saying it why
um a few of the sort of tv presenters or
radio presenters i've spoken to share
that experience of their professional
lives
inadvertently making them
one-dimensional at some point in your
life you um
you kind of uh
not rebounded but you um you pushed that
life away
that kind of one-dimensional sitting
there doing tv or radio
can you tell me about the build up to
that moment and and what
it was that made you realize it was time
to move on or move forward or to leave
it was so many things um
i guess there's only so much discomfort
you can take and it and it's not
due to the people i was working with or
even the medium i was working in i just
didn't feel right in it some people are
made for it and they can do that job way
better than i could
and they have a level of comfort there i
don't think i ever found that level of
comfort i don't know why
um
but also i had stuff going on personally
that meant at one point in my life i
felt really really awful really awful i
was in a period of depression
and
i think when you're in that headspace
not much makes sense anymore and you
have to start questioning everything
if you want to get out of it otherwise
you just get stuck and i did get stuck
for a long time and i went on medication
and did everything that one does to try
and get your head above the water but
there has to i think be a moment of
self-inventory where
you look at everything in your life
objectively and you start to question
everything and i still have to face
those fears every now and then because
at the moment i'm promoting a new book
and i'm going to have to go on live tv
and i'm going to have to go on live
radio
and it fills me with acute anxiety
thinking about those things because
there are parts of that experience that
feel very synonymous with
not a great time in my life
so
i've had to make a lot of very difficult
decisions where there have been moments
where i've been either offered lovely
jobs or i've been doing lovely jobs but
i haven't been able to do them it's not
even been something that i've
cognitively had to think about so i
cannot put myself in that position at
the moment i might be able to one day
but at the moment where i'm at with my
life and
healing from stuff and also i've got
young kids
i don't want
too much extra stress where i don't have
to have it
but also
i i don't want to sit here
professing like i made all these
decisions i left everything i started a
new life because also i haven't been
offered many tv shows it's not like
people have been going please come and
do a big mainstream tv show it's current
my own feelings about
that world have coincided with me not
being offered very much and at times
being sacked i use the word sacked
you never get officially sacked you just
aren't on the show anymore and then
someone else is doing it you're still
sacked so you kind of get take taken off
the show for
whatever reasons they've changed up the
format whatever
and
so that kind of coincided with me not
feeling like i was really enjoying a lot
of a lot of it but i probably would have
still my ego still wanted to be asked
and to be doing the odd
bits and bobs on tv
um that speaks to the law of attraction
a little bit there because you know it
does it does reading about what you've
uh in your new book about what you say
about the law of attraction and because
you know 13 years old you were trying to
pull that world into your life and then
at some point you decided
probably
inside before maybe vocally because of
your ego that you no longer were
enjoying this and then it started to
fall away yeah i guess it happens to all
of us
in many ways whether it's about work or
people you you know that you have in
your life whatever it might be that
you do hopefully start to act less from
your ego and more from a very
deep
you know sort of gut
feeling place
and
that's a good thing
um but it means that there are going to
be changes and the people around you
will react in certain ways to those
changes and you might feel slightly
wobbly about those changes at first
because you know when i sort of decided
that i wanted to leave radio one i'd had
a great time at radio one i'd had some
bad times personally whilst i was there
but the opportunity in itself was a gift
i was very lucky to have had that job
and sort of interviewed all these
brilliant musicians no matter what level
i was interviewing them at it was a
privilege to do that
um
but when i decided that i needed a new
chapter and i needed something new and a
new challenge i don't think i had a
single person say to me that's a great
idea you know everybody was sort of
going why are you leaving you have a
brilliant job on a brilliant radio
station interviewing all these
amazing people so i think you can make
those decisions they won't often be
backed up by everyone around you
but if you know it's right
that little voice will only get louder
and louder and i had that for like
probably six months before i decided
okay i've really got to do this now.
that voice was just again and again
saying
try something you know try something
else do something new you know give
yourself a new challenge
but you've got to
i guess you just have to jump into the
void because you're not going to have
everyone go great idea i'm here to
support you
let's go there is a moment where when
you are acting from an authentic place
that you just have to jump what was that
voice saying
in the lead-ups you leaving radio one
what was that voice saying every day as
you came into work you sat there for
three hours how did you feel what was
what was going on in your mind
you know what although i had that
authentic
voice
and that sort of niggling feeling that i
needed to do something different there
was also a voice going
like who do you think you are leaving a
job like that i still had that voice
going on who the hell do you think you
are leaving that job what are you gonna
do next good luck i had that going on so
i had these two voices one saying
try something new
you know there's there's another chapter
to be had
i found the pressure of being live every
day
all encompassing at times and
the anxiety of that
was tough
and i also
didn't love having routine that was the
same every day because you do have a
very structured day when you've got a
live show every day
and part of me felt a bit like oh i'm
still feeling like i'm a bit at school
with that kind of structure
but as i said this other voice was going
what are you doing you're an idiot
you're full you never you're out of that
whole world of music where you get to go
to the brit awards and you're respected
in the world of music because when you
leave you're not it's quite instant all
of a sudden you're not invited to the
brit awards and you're not respected in
it because you don't have a key
party you don't have a platform to go
i'm playing this song because i love it
you're not important anymore so your ego
takes the bruising and that took about i
don't know five or six months to go oh
god that still hurts a bit that no one
really gives a [ __ ] about me anymore and
then
you get over it so none of it's easy or
a quick like i left that and then i
started happy place
there it has been a bumpy road with lots
of ego bruising and lots of like
worrying that it's all going wrong and
then brilliant highs of
magical things coming out of the blue
but that feels exciting rather than just
going with the easier route i guess
which it was it was an easy it was an
easier route
again reading through your story and you
talked about um experiencing depression
there for the first time i growing up
when i first read this word depression i
thought okay that must be something that
happens to other people right that's not
i don't and as i've as i got older and
started speaking to a lot of
psychologists and people like johan hari
who wrote lost the book lost connections
um i my view on these mental health
disorders and various sort of mental
health conditions started to develop and
evolve to realize that we're really all
every single person listening to this
now is i'm capable of experiencing one
of these disorders it's actually part of
being human these are in the view of
many but not always i don't think
anything is exclusive to anything but um
is a symptom of the way
we we live our lives sometimes right is
that accurate
from your experience in terms of it
being a symptom of something yeah um i
never go into too much detail about the
circumstance but i was dealing with some
heavy [ __ ] and things i didn't want to
deal with
and i didn't know how to cope and
i think prior to me having that quite
lengthy period of depression i don't
know how long because it's quite blurry
a year
two years
it could have incrementally been five i
don't know there was a real intense
period where it's very very bad whereas
on medication and i
didn't really want to leave the house
then it incrementally got a little
easier and there were bad patches again
so it's a little bit blurry around the
edges
but much like you growing up i don't
think i even heard the word growing up
it certainly wasn't something i heard in
the 80s or 90s i wasn't exposed to it
yet my mum has dealt with depression and
i probably sort of knew that growing up
but didn't know there was i just thought
that's my mum i didn't think there was a
label for it or there was it was a thing
but when i was writing my first book
happy
i said to my mum would you write a piece
for it about
depression i'd never said that word out
loud to her in in context of her own
experience and she literally sent back
this thing within about 10 minutes
because it was all there ready to go
but we'd never had that chat properly so
although i didn't know the terminology
there was a feeling of it and i
understood it and my mum's mum my nan
sylvia
she had nervous breakdowns
when my mum was younger and i heard a
little bit about that so i knew it was
sort of there in the family so you know
how much of it is hereditary how much of
it is circumstantial i don't know and i
think a lot of mine was circumstantial
and then
understanding that has led me to look at
lots of different ways to
you know eradicate awful memories move
on from the past
eradicating ugly emotions like shame
and
learning to like myself i think that's
been one of the big
sort of movements in my
own healing
and you talk very openly as well about
um panic attacks again something i was
none the wiser to until you know it's
funny because i look back at when i
started to learn about people's panic
attack experiences i look back and think
i think i had one yeah i remember a day
where i was i had a very strange
physiological reaction in my body and
started feeling really overwhelmed and
like i had all this energy building up
but i couldn't quite understand what was
going on with me and and when i started
reading a little bit about your
experiences with panic attacks you know
when you were on that motorway that day
for the first time um it kind of rang
true to the experience i had
talk to me about your what the first
panic attack you had you know
what you learned from that experience
and and uh the journey you've gone on
with that and with anxiety and panic
attacks well i didn't know it was a
panic attack like when i had that
experience on the motorway i was with my
friend claire
and we were driving home from somewhere
we've been it was probably a two-hour
journey
and all of a sudden i went really hot
and i was like i didn't say anything to
claire i was like what the [ __ ] is going
on took my coat off round the windows
down she was like do you mind shine the
windows freezing i was like i'm just
feeling a bit weird
and then i started to feel like i was
sort of leaving my body which is my
experience of
panic attacks and i pulled over
and it's even weird talking about it
because i can draw that i can feel it
it's under the surface i haven't had one
for a while but i that feeling is so
familiar to me now this was probably
five years ago
my heart was racing i had no idea what
was going on so i went and saw a doctor
and was like there's something wrong
with my heart you need to check out my
heart and see what's going on with me
because i've had this
strange experience did all the tests i
lost nothing wrong with you fit and
healthy thank the lord
brilliant next you know the next week
i'm faced with some
quite nerve-wracking tv prospects of
being on live tv at this point i hadn't
quite realized i had an anxiety around
it i was just plowing through it
on the way in i was
getting that same awful feeling of i'm
leaving my body i had it in the makeup
chair i had it before i went on air i
had it during the time i was on air
it felt torturous like i don't want to
have this why can't i just go back to
what i used to do i used to go on tv and
be like so relaxed or be on radio like
online shopping i was so chilled out and
then all of a sudden
this thing it felt like
something was like infiltrated my neural
pathways like why is this happening
and that's where
i started talking to lots of different
people and
you know again i thought panic attacks
happened to other people i was like i've
never
had that i don't feel panicked i feel
like i'm leaving my skin
that's a panic attack
to some people there are different
manifestations of it obviously
i think if you put me in the situation
of having to do
one of those triggering jobs i would
most definitely still have one which is
why i don't really put myself in that
situation anymore
again i don't think it'll always be the
case i'm sure i could do
more therapy
more everything
and get to a place of comfort
i can't be bothered at the moment i
can't be bothered
to put myself in a position where i
don't feel safe i'd rather
forge new pathways work-wise and feel
safe and i'm very fortunate that i have
the propensity to do that i haven't
always but i do at the moment so i'm
going with it
um all of my panic attacks are around
work i don't really have them around
social settings i don't really have them
around
any physical activity it's around
work judgment of others
etc
so i just have to at the moment not put
myself
in that position
quick one at this time of year we always
see a huge spike in the amount of people
that are buying huel and joining the
huligan camp i guess um and i think that
speaks to the role that heel plays in my
life but also the role it plays to a lot
of people's lives which was as we start
to get a little bit busier typically we
fall into the trap of going for
convenience food and convenience food
for a lot of us means like junk food or
lots of sugary stuff whereas huel kind
of safeguards us in that part of our
lives it's completely nutritionally
complete as you'll know from listening
to this podcast and i say it every
single time i've had more tags on
instagram of people joining huel in the
last i'd say couple of weeks of january
that i have in the whole last quarter of
the year so if there was a time where
you're thinking about giving it a shot
here's my recommendation try the salted
caramel flavor that's my personal
favorite we all have different
preferences the banana flavor i
absolutely adore i love the cinnamon
swell flavor and also the protein powder
the salted caramel flavor again that
sits on top of my fridge over there is
incredibly useful if you are working out
and you're trying to get high levels of
protein into your body give it a go tag
me on instagram let me know what you
think
and come and become a huligan with me
you said when you left radio 1 it was a
a bumpy road now you know everybody in
their life at some point will have to
make a big decision to leave a position
of certainty which might be certain
misery in the pursuit of
something a bit more uncertain and
unclear whether there isn't a promise or
a blueprint
of how to achieve the thing
they wanted to get to their happier
place no pun intended
so so tell me about that bumpy road so
you leave you make the decision i'm
leaving radio one what was the the bumpy
road first of all i think all change
requires a bumpy road i don't think any
change for a human is like smooth and
great even if like you say you've left
something that you don't like
to follow your heart that's a brilliant
thing to do but i don't think there are
many people that would say that was a
smooth transition
so i
left radio
um i had my second kid well second slash
fourth because i've got two step kids
i had the fourth in our family little
honey
and i
didn't really have much work going on i
didn't really know
i was still doing celebrity juice at the
time which was a lot of fun
um
and then i started talking to my
publisher
about
writing something that felt a bit more
honest
and we hadn't had a conversation about
anything at this point to do with my own
experience for life i don't think i'd
told
i'd probably told three or four people
that i had experienced depression and i
wasn't feeling great i still probably
wasn't feeling that great at that point
there was big highs and lows and luckily
my publisher was really up for me just
sort of
seeing what
you know came out of me if i started
writing
so i wrote the book happy
which was my first
go at writing about anything
true and real to me or even talking
about it i hadn't ever done an interview
that felt particularly
like properly raw
and luckily lots of people liked that
book which made me think oh maybe i
could
do that a bit more
and less of the
being the other person that's on the
telly
so very very slowly
this sort of snowball effect well i
wrote two other books calm and quiet
and then
podcasts were kind of becoming a bit of
a thing
and there was you know me and my manager
had talked about schleider podcast and
everyone was going what's the podcast
and we were like well should we just try
anyway
it's just sort of chatting
so i started being my friends to start
off with or like just ringing people
please come on this podcast remember
emailing dawn french like will you call
my podcast i don't know what that is but
if you come to my house yes so i went to
her house in cornwall she was one of my
first guests we're very lucky that
that we were able to make that happen
and um and you know happy place sort of
started
we started the ball rolling with it and
other things started happening but again
it wasn't a sort of a smooth ascent or
trajectory to
where we're at now
there have been loads of moments where
probably more just mentally and
internally i've felt like
am i getting this right
is this going somewhere
have i actually got anything to say
you know
is my
is my platform helping people and doing
something with positive impact it's
probably been more cognitive than like
real problems happening of course have
been problems and
things going wrong but the bigger
problems have been in my head
and me worrying about stuff and feeling
like i'm a failure or like i've made a
big mistake or that
there's something wrong with me nobody
wants me on the tv i'm flawed i'm too
weird or i'm too outspoken i don't know
what it is i'm i just don't fit into
that anymore and i've had to let go of
worrying about that
because it doesn't really impact me so
much anymore i don't have to be on the
tv to do the other stuff that i'm doing
but there was a big mental hangover of
there must be something wrong with me
because people
don't want me on their screens and all
the bosses don't want me on their
screens anymore so i've had to let go of
a lot of old
thought patterns that do not serve me
so i can really
forge ahead clearly like with proper
clarity and with all of my energy
to do something that's different that's
over here that i really want to do and
is that an ongoing
practice or battle yeah i think it's an
ongoing discipline which sounds really
boring but i think a lot of this stuff
is it can still be fun but i think you
have to stay
dedicated to being nice to yourself and
not letting these mental patterns
stop your creativity or stop you trying
new things or stop you putting yourself
out there
so
yeah i guess it is a daily thing and
also it's undulating because some days i
feel like yes i've got so much
excitement for this podcast that i'm
doing coming up or i can't wait to write
this new book and then other times
i don't feel like that i wake up feeling
like oh my god you know i'll go into the
compare and despair thing of everyone
else is doing
things slicker better
look at stephen and all his cool cameras
and look at all these lights i don't
have this and you get into all of that
mindset
so i
i undulate some days i feel great and i
feel really grounded in what i meant to
be doing and other days i feel like i'm
flying all over the shop and i don't
know what the hell i'm doing and that's
okay and i think it's important to talk
about that so people don't
look at you know people in the public
eye or people who are doing things well
and think oh they know what they're
doing they feel great all the time
i don't know do you feel like that i
don't feel great all the time no no so
with with that with that that discipline
do you think the objective is just to
get to a better place and not really to
like overcome
the limiting belief it's just to get to
a better place is that the objective for
you
i think the objective has to be always
just to like myself
because then the rest sorts itself out
it doesn't matter where you're going
what you're doing how you're trying to
do it
if you like yourself
none of that
really
matters so much but also
equally as well as it not mattering so
much it will all happen with more ease
anyway because you'll make better
decisions you'll set clearer boundaries
you'll turn up
truly as yourself because you like you
no matter what day it is or whatever
you're going through
you'll hang out with people that make
you feel good you'll do more of what you
love you'll do less of what you hate
you'll have less mental torture because
you'll think oh no i don't deserve to be
hearing all that crap today
and you'll talk in a kinder voice to
yourself so for everybody that has to be
it's not even a goal it's just let's
give that a try again today and just see
if i can like myself a bit more which
brings us i think nicely onto your brand
new book bigger than us um
which is about the power of finding
meaning in a messy world and you're
talking there about liking yourself part
one of that book talks a lot about i
just want to say before we get into the
book that it it really is just a really
remarkable read you're a very very good
writer and i i picked up the book and i
thought maybe i'll skim whatever from
there from
from
and i
opened it and i just found myself sucked
into it and i said this to you before we
start recording because you're so
descriptive in the way you write that i
felt like i was it wasn't a book it was
more of like a movie i was inside the
scenario so you start in in part one of
the book talking about this sort of
self-compassion experiment
so tell me about what this
self-compassion experiment is and and
what it what it taught you and how it
helped you with those limiting beliefs
well first of all thank you because i've
had not so much feedback on the book
because it's not out yet so it truly
really means a lot that you've said that
oh yeah because this is where this is
ahead of time it's out now everyone it's
out but at the time of the recording i
haven't had as much feedback only from
luckily my publishers who really like it
but i'm it really means a lot that that
you got that from the book so i'm i'm
super grateful um
but self-compassion i didn't really know
where this book would take me
i knew the subjects i wanted to cover
i didn't know what the themes would be
at the start that kind of appeared later
down the line as the book kind of formed
but the first section did very much um
end up
sort of seeped in the theme of
self-compassion
and i guess the starting point was
talking to wendy who is a shaman that i
know wendy mandy and she's lived with
many indigenous tribes and
uh shamanic people the world over i
won't say how old she is but she's done
this for decades and decades
and every message seemed to go back to
self-compassion
and i've always known it's important but
i've certainly not practiced it because
you do have to practice it and i've
certainly not nailed it i've allowed
myself to get back into these loops of
like this acerbic voice that says i'm a
piece of [ __ ] etcetera
so i was like
if wendy's saying this again and again
and again and then so is the next person
i interview and the next person i
interview
then
i've got to
focus on this and it is a matter of
focus you can focus on all the things
you don't like about yourself
or you can choose to you know accept and
acknowledge that there are some things
you're not as good at and
mistakes you've made everyone has we are
human we are fallible humans but you can
focus on the stuff that
you really like about yourself and that
you really want to celebrate about
yourself and that you know and that you
notice the gifts that you have because
we've all got that every single person
has got
something to give
so it's a matter of putting your focus
and attention here or putting it over
here
so that was what i learned writing that
chapter was i need to focus more on this
stuff and not keep worrying so much
should i have said this have i upset
that person is it awful that 10 years
ago i did this thing that i really
regret you know we've all done that
there's no single person even the shiny
movie stars we see at the cinema or
people we see on instagram with 20
million followers they have all made
mistakes they all have ugly bits of
themselves they don't like silly things
they've done awful things they've said
slip-ups they've made
you know they've done things not from a
benevolent place we've all done it
but we can choose to not
live in that area the whole time and
like focus on it and drown in it and we
can look at the stuff that we do
want to celebrate about ourselves with
acceptance you haven't got to ignore and
shun
the shadow side because we've all got
that but have an acceptance of it
alongside celebrating the good stuff
i think is really what i learned from
writing that that chapter and in
practical terms how do you celebrate how
do you celebrate
the good stuff and try not to
let the mind wander away when you wake
up in the morning and you start
immediately thinking about oh my god my
my hair is this my nails are that why
haven't i done this i'm a bad mum et
cetera as you write about in the book
how do you what's the practical kind of
like discipline that you've engaged in
to be more self-compassionate i'm quite
lucky in the fact that i'm a very
obvious person so i can see myself very
obviously my habits are obvious and
they're big
and my big one
is to work too much and to be a
workaholic and to put the kids to bed
and then keep working until i'm
exhausted and my husband's like shut
your [ __ ] laptop like what are you
doing just
stop like what are you doing
and sometimes that is coming from a
place of wanting to do well some of the
time
a lot of the time probably 80 of the
time
that is coming from a place of i'm a
shitty person i don't deserve what i've
got i don't deserve to have the job that
i've got i've made mistakes i'm an idiot
i have to work harder if i am to believe
that i deserve
where i'm at
that's where that's coming from so i can
see it it's obvious when i go into
workaholic mode i go
oh i don't i must be not liking myself
very much now i'm beating myself up
about something
within me and it's deep rooted you have
to get down to that place of
what is this that i don't like about
myself
and on the days that i choose to do
something nice for myself and i'm not
talking about anything fancy i'm talking
about going for a walk that to me is
bliss
headphones music walking i'm in heaven
going for a walk
resting like allowing myself time out
allowing myself time where i'm not
worrying about emails and
how well the podcast is doing and here's
my book selling and just being and
hanging out with nice people or having a
friendly chat with someone then i know
that my actions are coming from a place
where i'm at peace with myself that day
so i'm obvious it'll be different for
everyone but you can probably spot the
patterns where you're in a little
negative cycle
versus the ones where you're being
nicer to yourself
what have you done practically as well
in your life to avoid putting yourselves
in scenarios where your your self
comparison is going to be triggered
because i imagine in the in the
mainstream like tv world i'm like just
tiptoeing into it dragon stands out this
week so you're starting to get invited
to these places that i don't really want
to be at
don't go yeah yeah i'm like with my team
i know that i just said no i don't want
to go no i don't want to go like i get
some really great invites and i'm just
like no i don't know
like obviously one of the probably
one of the only things i've done in
recent times was go to jake's charity
thing which was thrown out which was so
nice i think i cried at one point that
was gorgeous outside of that all the
other invites as glamorous as they are
it's just not me and i'm like um but
what do you do on a practical level to
avoid putting yourself in scenarios that
you know
i mean social media is the global
scenario of self-comparison but
to to to stop yourself being sucked in
to i don't think you can i don't think
anyone can in this day and age so
it's less about
the situations i put myself in
and more about how i choose to receive
that information because it is just
information whether it's looking at how
we quantify our popularity this new
framework of look how popular this
person is and that must mean something
or if it's just in your own friendship
group you haven't been invited to a
party or whatever the hell it is when we
try and
look at where we fit into it and how
high up are we on the ladder or whatever
or how far down am i on the ladder it's
how you receive that information it's
not reality we're all
beautiful beings of benevolent light we
we are that that all of us are that yes
we'll make mistakes yes we'll do shitty
things but we are all beautiful amazing
humans that are deserving of love and
kindness whether that's from ourselves
or other people
so the rest of it is a bit of a game
show so i think i just try and extract
myself mentally from it meaning too much
and just go
you know like i say like some
it's undulating on a bad day where i
already feel like [ __ ] myself i
could look at the podcast chart and go
oh my god i'm not even in the top 10.
what does this mean i'm not relevant
anymore la la and then i'm off on a
cycle of hell with breaking myself about
how crap i'm at my job
or
on a good day where i've woken up and
i've done a few things i know you make
me feel good i can then look at
something like the podcast chart or
instagram and go okay there are people
who are enjoying the work that i'm
putting out there
i'm grateful that's amazing that i have
the opportunity to talk and do a podcast
or write a book or whatever it is and
i'm i'm naturally more inclined to feel
grateful than i am to worry about where
i fit into it all so it's
much less about where i put myself now
because i think for all of us it's
inevitable that we're going to see
ourselves in some sort of system or some
sort of
framework of society and just look at
how i'm imbibing that information and
how seriously i'm taking it
not easy
it's not easy and it's
much easier for me than it is a lot of
people there are some people that
have
such a difficult situation in life
because systemically they're not looked
after people in the disability community
if you can't get into a shop because
there isn't a ramp there
where do you feel you fit into society
you know that is
unfair that is
that is not a nice place to be
where you are
whether it's physically or mentally
unable to slot into parts of society
because the framework isn't existing
i'm lucky because
i am able to
move around in society
with ease mine's more cognitive and a
silly mental game i play with myself
because of
you know in the past thinking i'm a
shitty person etc so i think we have to
notice how much of it is practical which
is unfair and we need systemic change
versus how much of this am i putting on
myself
how horrible am i being to myself
why am i comparing myself to people i
don't know etc so it's easier for me to
do that than for some people where
systemic change is desperately needed
and you're you're quite an introverted
person as well aren't you in terms of
you don't really you're not out there
partying or going to these glitzy
glamour events or anything do you
consider those mentally to be unsafe
places yes i think i used to believe i
had to go because people had to see me
out and i had to be seen in a cool place
wearing the best dress or whatever
and you know occasionally i'll go to the
odd thing if there is some meaning or
support for a friend or whatever
but i haven't been to something like
that in a very very long time um and i'm
an introvert in the truest sense
if i've done a podcast of my own or i've
or when i finish this episode with you
today
i will be tired
like an old lady like i need to go home
and be quiet i'm going to take my doors
to swimming later just me and her
and we will just have some quiet time
like i'm not the sort of person that
after i finished even if it was like the
most amazing episode and it was this
cool big celebrity i'm not the sort of
person that then wants to go out and
drink champagne to be like yeah let's
all be in a gang and celebrate that i am
drained
drained to my call and i need to go to
bed early and read a book before bed and
be on my own so although my job is to
communicate and i love talking to people
more than any other thing on the planet
i need something to counter balance that
and that is
solitude and tranquility
and
just peace and being a hermit quite
frankly
solitude tranquility and being a hermit
in the in the first part of your because
where you talk about your relationship
with meditation and what it's taught you
one of the really interesting sort of
conclusive points you make there is that
it taught you that our thoughts we
aren't our thoughts
and i think we all obviously we all go
through life thinking we are our
thoughts because that is the voice in my
head it's it's the control center so if
it says stevie a piece of [ __ ] i'm gonna
go okay we're a piece of [ __ ] yeah so
talk to me about that disassociation
you've you've learned with your thoughts
and was that a moment in your life that
that the penny dropped or
i think
i've heard a lot of people say it
i've had a lot of people say you are not
your thoughts and i've gone oh that's
kitsch i'm like that's cool
but i've never really applied it and
then i think again writing this book and
talking to jambo specifically in the
book about this subject
and he had a really brilliant and sort
of a more fun way of describing that
voice in our head especially when we go
into meditation and i'm not a daily
meditator
i do a lot of walking meditation rather
than seat which is actually luckily a
sort of lovely buddhist concept not that
i'm buddhist or aligned to any religion
but it's very much done by buddhist
monks there's seated meditation
and walking meditation and i can deal
with walking meditation a lot better i
can go out into nature with no phone
nothing and just walk and look around me
and i enjoy that more than sitting and
there's you know that's a great
introduction for me to get into it
but jambo talks about this moment where
you sit down and you try and have this
peaceful moment and then you've got the
voices they start and they might be
really mean and it might be like you
said you're a piece of [ __ ] or it might
just be
oh my god i haven't emailed back this
person or just silly lists of things we
haven't done
and he likens it to
you you're listening to your ego you're
actually sat there without any
distraction of a phone a laptop noise
being around people and you're listening
to it and you have to go to your ego
come here babe what's going on
get come it stop it's fine you don't
need to waffle on about i know this
story you've told me this before
and you you listen to it because we
don't in the day we're trying to
distract ourselves from that voice
oh my god i'm just gonna eat some
biscuits because i can't deal with all
that crap in my head right now i'm gonna
or i'm gonna work i'm gonna work until i
am exhausted or i'm gonna just scroll on
social media we'll do anything to not
listen to that
and there's nothing wrong
with that egoic voice we've all got it i
don't think the key or the aim is to
banish it from our minds and go
this voice can't exist i must be egoless
because unless you're living
on a mountaintop in scarlet robes as an
amazing enlightened being it's highly
unlikely in the modern world we're going
to have that experience so we listen to
it and you can have all the thoughts and
the chatter going but you don't have to
believe it and you don't have to act on
it you just simply
listen to it
and then you and then you might
afterwards after your meditation you
might go for a walk or you might even
like another thing i learned in the book
do some non-religious praying where you
go right i just noticed that my ego kept
saying i'm a piece of [ __ ] because this
happened and the voice in my head this
ego kept saying that i am not worthy of
whatever it is
so whoever you decide to pray to
whatever it is it doesn't have to be a
god or
a being it can just be a prayer sent
outwards
please help me with this awful
thought process that i have i don't want
it anymore i want to notice and
recognize my own
worth and love so it's quite a nice
combination that i learned about in the
book meditating
followed by by a non-religious or if you
are religious a religious prayer
beautiful but it's quite a
powerful kind of listening and and then
asking
sort of balance
on that listening and asking in the
second chapter of your book you you talk
about how
just like one thought for your life had
really
this one unhelpful thought that
underlied pretty much everything in your
life had um caused irregular moods it
caused you to turn down work it caused
you to think not so well of yourself and
as you describe it in the book feeling
like your rib cage was outside of your
heart your body for 10 years and this
underlying thought you had which you've
talked about there is that you didn't
deserve better
um
we all have this right we all have this
these underlying
self-opinions i'll call them of
ourselves that are inadvertently and
sometimes usually unconsciously like
running the show of our lives
if i was to ask you
how does one find out what these self
opinions are
um so that we can be liberated from them
how do i do that i think you get quiet
because the more we distract ourselves
the less
we know about ourselves
and we're just living via other people's
projections of us
so we become what your work colleagues
think of you you become what your
parents think of you become what
your kids have said to you you become
the projection
the only way you will
really
understand who you are and hear that
voice
is by getting quiet
and that's not a one-off thing like oh
i'm just going to get quiet today and
see what happens it might be through
journaling through writing you know i've
just re-read the artist's way you do
your pages every morning you just write
what comes to mind
you're getting to know yourself god i
think this i didn't even know i was
thinking that you know it just spills
out of you if you don't like writing you
could speak it into your
memos of your phone or a dictaphone if
anyone owns one of those still um
or you could just go walking and listen
to that internal voice and know there's
nothing wrong with it it doesn't matter
that that internal voice keeps saying
something quite negative
you've just got to hear it and know it
and then
understand that it is not true
like that is a given for anyone whatever
that awful thing is that that's that
sort of cycle of thoughts in your head
i'm a piece of [ __ ] i'm not worthy i'm
underserving i'm a bad parent i'm a bad
partner i'm a bad friend
they are all lies like all of it
we've all made mistakes we've covered
this we've all made mistakes we've all
done things wrong we will continue to do
so for the rest of our lives but that
doesn't mean any of that stuff's true
we're just getting up in the morning and
trying
we're all just getting up and trying so
all of that stuff in your head is other
people's projections it's not true
and that is sometimes hard to swallow
because people think
no it is true i've lived my whole life
knowing that i'm a bad
whatever it is
and that almost keeps you
and i've had this personally it keeps
you safe and comfortable in that because
you don't try new things and you don't
push yourself
and you don't put yourself out there
because i can't i'm bad at that i'm an
idiot i'm not worthy of greatness
abundance whatever it is so you keep
yourself small and you build walls
around yourself
it's much scarier
to rally against that negative thought
and to have to try new things to try
again that's even harder
to try something you failed at or
supposedly failed at
but if you if you understand that those
thoughts aren't true
you give yourself the space and freedom
to try new stuff or to get into a
relationship again or to
have a best friend again if you got hurt
whatever it is it's scary to do that
stuff i've certainly been trapped in
walls like that before and believed that
negative voice because it's been quite
comfortable weirdly
but if you let them go and you
decide to scare yourself a bit there
there's all sorts of things you could be
doing in trying there's an expanse of
stuff you could learn or experience in
life so
i'm by no means a place where i'm like
nailing all this stuff but i've learned
even more by writing this book and i'm
even more willing
to give new stuff a try and to not
listen
to this voice that is yabbering on in my
head the whole time
you are like quite quite obviously a
testament to the power of journaling and
writing and um
putting your thoughts and feelings out
into the world because because you've
done that you've written so many books
you've recorded so many podcast episodes
it's quite apparent to me that the
self-awareness you exude is a is a
consequence of that and for me one of
the really unintended but really um
fortunate consequences of starting a
podcast was you had to look at your
thoughts a lot
and the diversio started with me in my
bedroom opened up my diary at the end of
the week and read out what it says and
that meant that i had to record a diary
and so i'd finish these podcasts after
week one two three and four and i'd go
oh my god i'm like my my self-awareness
is becoming heightened i'm understanding
things about my childhood that i never
knew before you know we often think
therapy is sit in a room speak to
somebody else but therapy for me was
writing in my diary and looking down on
the page right and so i just think that
i wanted to just highlight that because
i think it's the most important
understated easy dare i say thing that
someone can do is just to like look at
their thoughts on a regular basis
podcasting forces you to yeah um like
making quotes on instagram again forces
you to look back at your experiences and
not just let them pass you by without
the value extracted so i just wanted to
dwell on that for a second um because i
think everyone should do it and i say
this a lot i say everyone should like
keep the diary and just like right every
every week yeah
it's so therapeutic to do that so
therapeutic i mean i've written a diary
since i was
a tiny kid wow and i've said i've said
this before on my own i only said it
recently i only felt
i guess kind of brave enough to say it
out loud but i thought it would have
some worth because there'll be people
who have a similar thing going on
i wrote a diary since i was i don't know
12
nearly every night wow i had books and
books and books had
so when i went through my very bad
depression i burned all of them they
went i didn't want
to have a past so they went
my dad had there was a big incinerator
at work he took a big bag in said don't
look at any of them i want them gone
and i did regret it for a while
although i've also made peace that it
was actually
a bit of a ceremony a ritual for me to
like it went up in flames you know a lot
of good times were up in flames but
there was stuff i wanted in there gone
and i know you can't erase your past and
that's not what i'm looking to do but it
felt like i could at least start again
so i have started writing again and i
won't burn these ones and it feels
peaceful and
without standing self-indulgent it's
important it's important to me it's not
important to anyone else it was
important to me that i take that time to
do it so i i would always encourage
people to give it a go
you you've sat and interviewed so many
amazing people um and i've got to speak
to a couple of you know really great
people as well and i started to notice
some like gender differences
um
in
success ambition in
how certain people were much more
comfortable speaking about
their goals their finances their targets
their ambitions than other people what
have you noticed in this arena
oh yeah i know you're hinting dude
it's hard as a
woman and i can only speak from
experience a working mum
to
talk about certain things in a certain
way ambition being one because for a man
to say
you know i've got great ambitions it's r
it's been historically celebrated i'm
not saying anything out of terms it's
very obvious
for women that's quite a new thing
obviously there have been mavericks and
amazing women over the years who have
had huge ambition been game changing in
history they're probably less celebrated
in history but they've been there
but i do think it's still seen as
a different choice for women to say i'm
i'm very ambitious i am ambitious highly
ambitious
um
i'm also a mum and i'm a nurturing mum
who wants to bring her kids up well for
them to feel loved and supported and
safe
and it's hard to do both well i try but
i've had to let my social life totally
slide off the face of the earth to do
two things really well
or i'm not saying like my standards are
better than anyone else's for me for me
to feel like i'm doing them well
that i can cope with the level of work
and that i can cope with what's going on
my kids at home
it's really bloody hard whereas i look
at a lot of men in that situation who
have kids
and they don't have to worry so much
about being
vocal about the nurturing side of it if
they're off
doing a job overseas or whatever it is
there's no judgement whereas for a woman
to go away and
if they are working abroad or if it's
like a female musician going on tour
the judgment around
how what what their kids would be doing
and who's looking after them etc
is huge
and commented on i've had people i had
someone this is an example
someone said to me on instagram
a year or so ago and again no judgment
to this person this is just a story but
i had posted
me doing a yoga workout or i don't know
some sort of workout and they said
i feel deeply i don't know what it was
upset that you've posted this
for all moms out there that don't have
the time to do
a yoga workout or a workout this is
really difficult for me to see
and i and i just said to her
would you say the same to joe wicks
because he doesn't work out every day
and i don't think anyone's going who's
got you where's your kids who's got your
kids you've got two young kids where are
your kids because they've automatically
without thought gone oh his wife's got
the kids so he can go to the gym and do
a workout
i work more than my husband so yeah i'm
going to say to him i'm going to take 20
minutes out to go for a walk or to do
yoga
or can you do the school run so i can do
it
like it's
but it's it's a subconscious thing
people aren't sort of having these
thoughts and going oh this isn't fair i
need to bring this up this is
subconscious historic
you know problematic territory that
we're in
and
you know my parents generation were
probably the first generation to be
juggling
on math work and kids
so this is very new for women before
that like my nan's
they were sort of almost i think told by
my grandad no you're not working you've
got to bring up the kids we're at work
and they did it so this is new we're
still figuring it out and it's still
really hard and it's still really
painful and there's so much judgment
i had no meant to do about it but you
know keep trying and encourage the
younger generation of women growing up
now my daughter and step-daughter
to
move through with more ease
yeah um it's actually something i
noticed from doing this podcast was just
there was just this clear distinct
difference between
what it was really it was when i'd
invite a very very successful woman onto
this podcast to talk about her success
there was this kind of timidness
and especially when they if they were
also a mother there was this real
timidness that i just didn't see in the
men they would be very out there here's
how much i'm making it's 17.3 million
and and i would say and you know i'd
have i'd become friends with the person
and speak to them um after the podcast
for many many months and whatever and
they'd highlight that to me and say it's
different for you steve i could sit here
now and say how much money i'm making
how hard i'm working all of these things
i could also post it on my instagram and
i swear to god everyone would just clap
yeah but i know that chrissy chella who
is in a similar position really
successful
so you know running businesses if she
did that i know what the comment section
would look like and i just i feel like i
have an obligation to share that and to
talk about it a lot because it's not
fair
sadly though the comments would probably
be all from women which i hate to say
yeah
so we've been indoctrinated by the
patriarchy
maybe more so than men or certainly an
equal pegging and i had a chat with
kathleen moran about this you know it's
unfortunate that
the patriarchy is screwing over men as
much as it is women but it's also
indoctrinating women as much as it has
men
and we're fighting against it but we're
also still judging each other and going
how come she's got to do that well it's
all right for her she can do this or
whatever it is rather than celebrating
each other and going that's inspiring
that you've done that alongside being a
mother or not just being a woman in
business still not easy with or without
kids there's still judgment there's
still you know
all sorts of things to do with that
hierarchy that don't make sense for a
female to enter that system
so
there are you know
but i don't want to be too downbeat
about it because also that is
in itself there is excitement there for
women to make great changes to that
and to be part of a real positive
movement where we celebrate each other
and see for the younger generations that
eradicated so i think when there's a big
problem we also have to look at the
excitement in changing that because
that's a great big juicy challenge there
are you optimistic about it yeah
i am because i think you're in a real
position of power here as well to change
that well i hope so i think the bolder i
get in saying those things like yes i'm
ambitious yes i want to be
you know this or yes i am successful or
whatever it is with without cringing too
much
great but also i don't want to
underestimate
how young women today teenagers young
people in their 20s females
are already challenging that that
without the likes of me or anyone older
they're doing it because they see it and
they want to feel differently
and that you know i'll always be in
support of that but i think they're
already doing it because i think
the generation that comes next always
acts as a reaction to what's been and
we're still climbing ourselves out of
this hole
so
hopefully that's happening and i'm
seeing you know like even within my own
management my management company the my
managers who look after me
it's headed up globally by a female not
a similar age to me who i respect hugely
she's called mary i love her
and two other people that i work with
that are in my
management team holly and sarah
females and they're they're doing
brilliant work and they're leading huge
teams of people
so
i'm just happy to celebrate them and to
celebrate that and to hopefully just see
more of that going forward
bigger than us
the book is um largely centered on this
idea of meaning right that's the that's
the kind of overarching purpose for
writing the book it's trying to find
meaning in in a messy world and at the
end of the book in part four you start
to conclude that you know the real um
meaning in life is connection in its
various forms so i guess my question for
you is what is it that um for you now is
bringing meaning in your life what does
meaning mean to you in your life now and
uh yeah where where do you find it
i find it in really
simple places like going for a walk and
that sounds a bit too sort of casual and
flippant but i do
i try and go for a walk every day
and i went through this morning super
early it was sun was still rising it was
pissing with rain it's bloody horrible
but when i'm out i might be listening to
music i might go without my phone and
just walk
this could sound very cheesy but i'm
often brought to tears
because
i
i extract myself from the oh my god my
kids are late for school or i haven't
done this email or how am i doing with
this or what's failing with that
or i just let it all go
and i'm lucky to live near a very green
space so i can walk around and look at
trees and see there's green parrots in
the park and
whatever else is going on in nature
and be humbled by it because it's
humbling when you really
notice it or at night look at the sky if
you're lucky to live in an area where
there isn't too much light pollution and
see one star
that might not even be there anymore
because
we can't talk about physics it's gonna
blow my head off but you know what i
mean yeah
look at the greatness of what is going
on around us rather than at your phone
or the smallness of oh my god my house
is a [ __ ] how everything's messy and
look outside of that like i have to do
that every day
so i don't get bogged down with am i
doing this right where do i fit into
society how successful am i
all of this greatness and how short life
is
how short life is and that in 200 years
none of us are going to be here that's
humbling it's not bleak that's humbling
to get up every day and think
there's a whole new load of generation
like people and things will be happening
and systems in place and technology or
whatever it might be that i won't be
around for
so i have to get up and be grateful and
do all that stuff i want to do today not
next year when i'm braver in 20 years
when i'm older and quirkier and more
eccentric
i've got to do it now
so i have to find that meaning
connection
this is bespoke it'll be different for
everyone but for looking at the bigger
everything
noticing that i'm on a floating ball in
space
noticing that all of this is changing
always and there are trees thousands of
years old and i'm just 40 and what do i
[ __ ] know
i have to get myself out of this small
structure that we've created on a
societal level and look at the
hugeness of all of it and remember when
you look at that hugeness that we know
[ __ ] all
because we don't even we can't even get
our heads around the fact like what is
infinity what how no i can't even go
there we don't know anything
we know nothing
and we have to keep coming back to that
as soon as we start going yeah i know
everything about this and that you don't
i know more than you
small small lives small
i want big expansive i don't know
anything
i'm here to learn here to learn yeah and
i won't be here in however many years so
gratitude it's funny because it's i mean
yeah what you're saying is just is
beautiful and very very true and
powerful but from that i was i was i was
realizing that
my own self-importance is a curse right
so like if i log into instagram the
little like thing will tell me how
important i am today and then i'll get
sucked into that or if i'm a good enough
mother because i didn't pack the right
thing for sports day and this like the
the system we've created the kind of
like matrix we live in sucks us into
believing our own self-importance and
that you know the color of my my nails
really is consequential to anything and
as you look up at the stars you realize
that you are just a respect
the universe doesn't really give a [ __ ]
about you
and that is liberation it's liberation
from all the pettiness that consumes our
mind but i also think as much as we are
i don't want to use the word
insignificant but as tiny as we are in
the grand grand scheme of things
i also alongside that truly believe that
we are supported
by all of this greatness
not necessarily by the societal
structures that we see and we are told
about constantly but something bigger
something inexplicable something that
you might not even be able to label or
want to label but i do believe that
there is support
and what does that mean for you because
you start to write about this in the
book well i have never aligned with a
religion so it's harder to
talk about it eloquently because when
there's the infrastructure of religion
you can talk about a god a way of being
and a system that works which is
beautiful
i've never had that growing up i've
never aligned or felt drawn to it but i
deeply feel that i can communicate with
the world around me which in turn when
you get on this macro micro micro level
is within you it's all the same thing we
are made of the same stuff
so that might link to
non-religious prayer and having a
communication with that something bigger
it might also be the law of attraction
which you touched upon earlier where you
are manifesting the things that you're
cognitively thinking about and focusing
on you're seeing more of what you're
focusing on so you know look for red
cars when you stop listening to this
you'll see bloody loads like look
and see what you're wanting in your life
and more of it will appear
lots of the things i talk about in the
book
describe and support that notion there
is something bigger at play that we are
part of that we
can feel supported by which will
hopefully then
you know eradicate loneliness or people
feel disconnected from the world around
us and
then force more into sort of habitual
negative cycles or whatever it might be
so
there are lots of ways i think you can
tap into it and that you can
explore it and have fun with it it's
exciting like doing a little ritual in
the ritual sub um chapter i love doing
rituals that's such a gorgeous way of
honoring a moment for you to place
meaning into something for you to
seek the meaning find it and honor it
there's meaning in everything we just it
just passed the spikes we're in a bloody
rush
so hopefully in the book i go through
lots of different ways in which
i you know i can
articulate what that means to me and
some of it might resonate with you some
of it might not but for me i found each
subject very exciting it was a new
communication tool to
communicate with everything around me
the way you approach those topics as
well you approach it in a very humble
way in a very a way that feels very
inclusive in the book so like i could um
investigate the idea of like
non-religious prayer um because it
didn't feel like wishy-washy you
described it in a very human way as
being
you're speaking you're kind of putting
your thoughts out there you don't know
who you're doing it to
but you know a lot of people when they
write about these topics would probably
give it a name and a yeah whatever so it
felt very very relatable and i actually
probably when i was reading that thought
i could see how non-religious prayer
would help me in my life yeah what is
what is non-religious prayer and i'm so
glad that you've said this because that
was my whole aim for this book
was for this to be
everyday stuff yeah exactly it's not woo
it's not exclusive to a certain
demographic who can afford to do it or
they're in the right time and place to
do it this is we can all do this is the
basics
this is the basics of life that we're
sort of ignoring
and it's the simple and it's the fun and
it's the curious
and they're the things that we usually
lose because we're in a bloody rush so
so non-religious prayer which my friend
donna lancaster has taught me about
beautifully
i was probably already doing it to an
extent because i've always
had some sort of communication with
sometimes i'll say dear universe or
whatever sometimes i just speak
or i'm just in my head
like before i go to bed now i'm more
sort of disciplined about it in the fact
that i'll put my head on the pillow
and i'll say first of all a prayer of
thanks for whatever's gone that day or
just the general state of how i am i'm
healthy i'm in a warm bed
god thank you for that like whoever
you're talking to thank you for my warm
bed i'm so lucky
then i'll go for a list of people that
i want to send a message of prayer to
you know whether it's someone that's in
need of of help of support
and that they find some comfort and then
i'll go to the tricky a bit which is to
ask for something that i need
and i find that bit sometimes quite hard
again because of everything we've talked
about
um
i deserve this i deserve a little help
in this department or some guidance
and i think as long as you think of it
as a fun curious thing to do
what's the harm in it you're not signing
up to some sort of like
new religion or cult that you're joining
it's a fun thing to try to have
and watch for the results that's what i
would say be curious in
what happens next and the guidance if
you're looking for the signs
that appears like weird coincidences and
stuff that happens
that you can't ignore you can't ignore
them the signs are everywhere if you've
got your eyes open
some people are just so unwilling to
step outside of the um
step outside of the measurable yeah and
what i mean by that is well i can't you
know i've got kpis for my life so if
i've got an instagram i need likes if i
do this i need money i need if i do this
i need this what you're talking about
there is going for a walk in the park
how do i measure the return on
investment
if i do a prayer at night time how do i
measure that this is working what do you
say to people that think in that school
of thought which is a lot of people
specifically men
i would say measure how good you feel
measure how like talking about
how connected you feel is difficult
because you can't quantify that you
can't see it
you know it hasn't got a flavor or a
color
what is that feeling of connection
so first of all look at all the times
where you felt disconnected we can all
remember a time we felt
hugely disconnected from other people
from nature
when you are buying [ __ ] you don't need
disconnected from the natural beauty
that is around us when you're bored and
you're sat around thinking life [ __ ]
they're all moments of disconnection
so just when you feel the opposite of
that
you're you're getting the return
and also i think it's we've got to stop
looking at
the return
we've got to start looking at just being
and it's not always about being
the best the most successful
having the most whatever it is
quantifying anything and it being the
most it's about being part of a
a huge network of people and animals
please can we not forget there's
beautiful animals out there that we're
just totally disregarding
all day every day who have probably more
of a right to be on this planet than we
do
we are part of a huge
massive connectivity and we can feel the
beauty of that we can feel that
energy pulsing through us whenever we
choose to we deny ourselves of it all
day every day
and we're about the singular the insular
what can i get what can i do for me
it's not
global you know parts of the world more
so in the east
still have much more connection
obviously to nature but also to
community to each other to not looking
for a social pecking order to be part of
something
when you feel part of something
you feel alive and it hasn't got to be
like you being at a party with loads of
people but you feeling part of a
movement a collective in a non-exclusive
way it's not about then others being
outside of that feeling part of
something just feeling your connection
to nature
that is a beautiful starting point in
any day to feel that connection the rest
is a bonus if you can feel that that is
a lovely lovely thing it's not a return
like what can nature give me what can
other people give me how can i feel part
of this rather than separate from it our
separateness has caused us
so much pain
and we don't even see it
and that like so perfectly um speaks to
the journey you've been on where you
said the measure how you feel because as
we when we start this conversation um
you shared some stories about being in
the radio and in tv and in those
environments where you probably
weren't as good at measuring how you
were feeling but you were more focused
on the external um quantifiable kpis of
or society's society's view of how you
should be feeling based on the material
success of your life
um really really powerful i think
sentiment to to end on is that idea of
measuring how you feel i do want to ask
because you know this is a business
podcast that's the category we sit in
happy place big brand now what's your
what's your it started as a i guess it's
kind of from what you said it started as
this book which developed into a podcast
now it's a festival you have a
publishing business what is your what
you want happy place to to be
i do have
big ambitions for happy place
and
we've tried to sort of sit as a team and
work out what is the goal
and we keep landing on the same thing
and it is to help as many people as we
can in varying ways
and in fun ways and in ways that are new
to them whether it's a book a festival
an expert a live experience
something digital
we're constantly wanting to connect
people for them to feel less alone and
to help them in some way of course
within a business structure so there's
lots of business stuff that goes behind
that sort of nice benevolent thought of
helping as many people as we can
so we're looking at loads of ways to do
that and to introduce people to the
subjects
that that sit within a happy place if
it's your first time
learning you know or hearing about
non-religious prayer you're pretty
cynical about spirituality or even
you're moving into the territory of
looking at mental health for the first
time that hopefully there's something
within our business plan on our platform
that doesn't feel scary to you or alien
to you and that will allow you to
listen to a new conversation or learn
something new
hopefully at a very accessible or free
level
um to
connect people for people to feel less
alone and for us to reach as many people
as we possibly can doing that
and do you think are you in a happy
place now
yeah
i am
i think i've got a lot more layers to
peel back
i think i've got a lot more
um
[Music]
digging around to do to get to a place
where i am
truly authentic in myself i still have
that romantic notion or image of myself
aged
hopefully say 80
with loads of crazy jewelry and wild
gray hair and being completely eccentric
and out there
and i i wonder why i'm not just doing
maybe not the gray bit although who
knows but well i'm not just doing that
now i see myself as hugely authentic
down the line
and i'd like to have the courage to step
into that sooner
so i think the quicker i do that the
happier i will feel and that's just an
everyday thing of waking up do i feel i
can truly show up as myself today
or
i don't i feel vulnerable i feel fragile
maybe i don't today but i'd like to be
more and more
in the space where i can just be me
and like myself for that person i think
that's where my happiness will live
that picture in my head of that
eight-year-old with the rings and the
gray hair what's the difference between
that person and who you are now in in
real terms what's the
what's what is the difference uh well
hair dye being obvious um i would say
um
i still do things because i feel i
should sometimes
because i think well i
how could i possibly
sell a book do whatever
unless i do the bit that i find
uncomfortable whereas i hope to be at a
level one day
where
i'm just doing the stuff that really
makes me happy and i know that that's
a real privilege to be in that place
but i would like to at the age of 80 to
have
earned some
i guess space to just doodle around
doing things that i really like
and to hopefully encourage others to do
the same
without the [ __ ] yeah and without the
voice in your head going oh we should be
doing this she should be doing that that
will be i'll be so bored of that by then
that'll be just so dead to me
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast which is um this is the diary
and what we ask is the previous guest to
write a question for the next guest so
and i actually and i swear to everything
that this is the truth i don't see the
question until i open this book so
sometimes i can't read their writing so
bear with me if i can't but our previous
guest wrote a question for you they
didn't know who they're writing it for
um and i'll tell you i might tell you
who they are later but i typically don't
um because it might distort the way that
the question okay interesting
if you had a twin
what is the most important bit of advice
you would give them
i think it goes back to everything we've
just talked about and that is to be
100
you
don't mask bits of yourself you don't
like
don't pretend to be
fancier cooler smarter than you actually
are
literally just be you
i love that
thank you so much and you know what
thank you thank you so much for writing
that book because um for someone like me
who's going on my and you know i told
you about my girlfriend she lives in
bali she's the reason i have crystals
around my neck as we speak
um for someone that's going on that
journey of understanding the more
metaphysical parts of life and
spirituality and uh energies and these
kinds of things it felt really inclusive
as i said so but also the way the book
is written is really enjoyable because
of as i said how descriptive and
wonderful it is so um and that was the
first book of yours that i'd read but i
remember thinking oh my god if they're
all like this then i want to read all of
them i'll send you them i'll send you a
whole bunch
they can be door stops if they're not
your thing but um hopefully you'll like
them but i really don't i don't tend to
blow gas at people's asses if i don't if
i don't really like something i'll just
talk about something else but it was a
really really phenomenal book i think um
i think my listeners especially are
going to really really enjoy that book
and it is out right now um anywhere it's
called bigger than us um and yeah it's
out now 20th of january it came out so
yeah so i hope everybody enjoys it thank
you for your time thank you stephen i so
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you
oh
[Music]
[Music]
bye